all right y'all we are back and last
year I met a 9-year-old aspiring writer
who's absolutely obsessed with the Diary
of a Wimpy Kid series there isn't a
picture a plot point or a subtle joke in
the books that Jacob has missed what
Jacob didn't know though is that the
author of the series Jeff Kenny was here
and had an offer for Jacob we knew he
couldn't refuse so let's take a look are
you a fan of books you like you like
reading yep yeah is di a Wimpy Kid one
of your favorites yep well we actually
have a surprise for you do you want a
surprise yes okay okay the creator of
the Diary of a Wimpy Kid series Jeff
Kenny is here and wants to meet you is
that cool yeah look at you right now
come on out
Jeff come on
[Music]
out Jacob this is awesome I can't
believe I'm getting to meet you you're
like a legend thank you for being a fan
but I also wanted to say I have a studio
in planville Massachusetts in my
bookstore on the top top floor and I
would like to invite you to spend time
with me in the studio draw on my
computer and talk about books and talk
about jur books does that sound like a
good idea yeah all
right great all right let's see on the
deal well the day arrived when Jacob got
to meet Jeff at the studio and it was
pretty epic so check this
out I'm here today with Jacob at my
bookstore and unlikely story in
planville Massachusetts I get to finally
show you around are you excited to see
the wimpy kid Studio yes excellent okay
let's go we're going to tour the
bookstore at Diary of Wimpy Kid Studios
and then we're going to do some drawings
together Jacob welcome to my
bookstore I'm really excited to be here
at an unlikely story do you like it so
far so far yep so far yep I don't often
get to spend time one-on-one with fans
especially fans who know so much about
the series so this is a really special
day for me do you know who this is Greg
that's right that's Greg hefley I really
loved his latest book no-brainer because
Greg's luck was changing he actually got
a girlfriend for once I understand
you're an author yourself is this true
yes I have a little surprise for Jacob
waiting on the shelves why don't you
pull that book
out John versus the cleps it's your
book pretty cool huh yes flip it open
you're going to get to see your own work
in print Je me to pull out this book and
it's my book John versus the gurps isn't
it cool to see your work in a book form
yes yes it was really exciting seeing
Jacob find his book on the bookshelves I
think he sees that he could become a
published author you've seen the
bookstore but you haven't seen the wimpy
kid Studio are you ready for the main
event yes great let's do it let's go I'm
100% most excited to see the studio
where Jeff works on his books no
way
welcome to the Wimpy Kids
Studio isn't it cool oh
my we've got lots of cool stuff from the
wimpy kid
Universe he's a super fan of the books
with a deep knowledge so this is going
to be more special for me than it is for
him because I'm going to get to see it
through his eyes check it out do you
know what this is right here the Cheese
Touch that's right Greg is actually
touching the cheese here now do you know
Greg heffley's favorite video game
Twisted wizard Twisted wizard we have a
Wimpy Kid airplane room over
here Jacob's got something really
special about him his mind is always
going his eyes are looking around the
room he's taking it all in you think
it's cool yes I'm actually starting to
work on the cover for my new book How
would you like to work with me on the
cover of the new
book sounds like fun all right let's do
it he's been a fan of the series and now
he's a part of the story my idea is that
Greg is sitting in a giant bowl of
spaghetti so do you want to draw like a
bowl underneath the giant pile of
spaghetti like I think it would be down
here right and like that this is so cool
the most exciting part of today was
working on the cover with Jacob perfect
perfect yeah and then since it's
checkered how about right over
here and
excellent I think this this looks really
good I think we're on the way to the
cover for Book 19 Jeff is so cool
because he showed me around his studio
and he let me draw with him this is
probably cooler than anything I've ever
done in my entire life I hope that I
inspired Jacob on his journey to
becoming an author but he really
motivated me this was just the spark
that I needed to work on the next book
thank you so much for coming to the whiy
Kids Studio did you have fun today
definitely I can't wait to see what you
come up with next you've inspired me
with some good ideas oh that's
awesome we've got the author of the DI
of a wimpy kids series Jeff Kenny here
along with one of his biggest fans and
aspiring children's author himself
nine-year-old Jacob give it up for him
yall so last week Jeff Dave Jacob aore
of his studio and together they worked
on the cover for Jeff's new book so what
was your favorite part Jacob of visiting
Jeff's place my favorite part was when I
walked into the studio and saw the Giant
welcome Jacob
son when I beat Jeff Kenny at his own
video
[Laughter]
game when I saw my own book on the Shelf
oh that's exciting and when Jeff let me
help out with the new with the next
cover of his book of his next book that
is super cool I know what an honor what
what so Jeff what do you hope that Jacob
got from the visit well I think it's
really cool that he can see an author as
a real person you know growing up I only
saw an author as the name on on the
cover of a book but it's really
important to know that there are there
are people behind the the words that you
read in your favorite books yeah
absolutely and did did you I don't know
did you did the visit make you want to
be an author even more so
now I've never met a professional author
and yes it did make me want to be a
author even more because maybe I'll end
up with a cool Studio like Jeff's
instead inste instead of a boring Studio
like my instead of a boring office I
mean like my
[Laughter]
dad oh my God you're you could also be a
comedian um that was amazing no it is
fun I remember we showed your office
last time and I was like that's magical
and it's so inspiring all the colors
like how it's set up it's very bright so
do you have any advice for Jacob yeah
Jacob uh first of all you're already a
Creator so you're already on your way a
lot of kids like just play a lot of
video games and stuff like that but
you're actually making books already and
what I'd say is the best thing that you
can do is to find people who will give
you honest criticism if you want to get
better like if you show your books to
your parents you know your grandparents
they'll say oh this is so great you know
we love what you've done but if you can
find somebody who will give you real
criticism it'll help help you to grow
yeah it'll push you yeah and so when I
was a kid I had a teacher in the fifth
grade named Mrs Norton and she could see
that that I liked comedy and I wanted to
get better and so she gave me really
good criticism that was hard criticism
one time she saw me practicing a skit
with my friends for a talent show and
she walked in the room and she said you
know what there's a difference between
laughing at and laughing with and she
told me that we were on the wrong track
and I always remember that and it helped
me get better it was hard to hear honest
criticism but it helped me to grow as an
artist absolutely do you do you have
anybody in your life like that now that
you show your work to and they give you
like kind of like oh pointers on what
you did
uh I have my friend Gus he does I don't
really show my work to him sometimes I
do but he does give me honest criticism
okay that's good that's a good friend
honesty that's where it's at yeah well
Jeff you and Jacob are working on the
cover for your newest book right that's
right my my new book is coming out it's
called hot mess and Jacob and I came up
with this idea where um Greg is like
sitting in a giant pile of spaghetti
what was your favorite part about that
Jacob drawing that together
all of it all of it it was really cool
because I've never done this with a fan
and Jacob's a real fan of the book
series so it was really cool because
what you worked on with me is going to
get seen by millions of people Isn't
that cool yes yeah yes he is like
absolutely it'll get me to that studio
instead of the boring office job yeah we
we have the finished book cover Jeff and
Jacob were working on so Jacob you want
to reveal it you haven't seen it yet
right this is your first time after you
creating it this your first time to
really see
[Music]
it do you like it yeah oh my gosh well
come on back over come on back over
should I'll take it I'll okay watch this
beep
up that's it's fun to have your own show
um Diary of a Wimpy Kid hot mess which
is the perfect cover for this book is
out October 27th we're going to be right
back with what I'm liking great job
[Music]
[Applause]
guys thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home